Hi there!
Today we
are discussing the Swin Transformer.
Swin stands here for Shifted WINdows
and is basically a vision transformer variant but
with a hierarchical way of processing the image.
So, if you are curious about
this vision transformer beast,
reportedly beating many benchmarks,
grab a cup of coffee because it
is time for an AI Coffee Break!
Speaking of motivation for the Swin Transformer:
Reading this part of the abstract
triggered me a little bit:
It is about the “Challenges in adapting
Transformer from language to vision".
And the authors say, they "arise from
differences between the two domains,
such as large variations in the scale
of visual entities and the high resolution of
pixels in images compared to words in text.”
This is such a computer vision
researcher thing to say!
Everything is big data if you are brave enough.
Words in text can become too many too if one wants
to handle a complete Dostoyevsky
novel as one single data point.
But yes, point taken from the authors here, that
there are more images in this world than novels,
so funnily, while transformers with linearly
scaling attention can handle entire novels as
one sequence, there are not enough novels written
to create significant datasets in this way,
so yeah... text transformers usually
work with smaller sequences and text
is usually processed at a sentence-level.
Anyway, back to the Swin Transformer here.
It is based on ViT and to remember
how the Vision Transformer works,
you can check out our video on this.
Because here, we are going
to put it into a nutshell:
the image is decomposed into 16x16 pixel patches,
then these patches are transformed into
patch vectors by a linear transformation.
These patch vectors combined
with positional embeddings,
are processed by a transformer in the same
way in which the transformer processes
word vectors, which we also
discussed in a previous video.
But, there is a problem with the
vision transformer that the authors
here try to alleviate with the Swin Transfomer:
the problem is related to
the extraction of patches;
a step which is particular to images, not to text.
If the image is let’s say… 256x256 pixels,
then extracting 16x16 pixel patches
would lead to 16 patches, thus 16
image vectors would form a sequence.
But an image of 1920x1920 pixels would
already lead to 120 image vectors,
which is still ok with bigger
and bigger GPUs, of course.
And if we do this to solve tasks
where looking at 16x16 pixel patches
is not too coarse, then ViT is still ok.
And this is the case for tasks that are, in
a sense, summarizing the image, like it’s the
case with image classification, where the goal
is to predict one label for the entire image.
Analyzing the image through big
patches is not that problematic here.
But there are tasks, where one really needs
detailed information at pixel-level, not patches.
Such a task is semantic segmentation where
the algorithm needs to decide for each
single pixel in the image,
what class this belongs to.
In this case, 16 by 16 pixel patches are way
to big. So ideally, we would like to handle
every pixel as a token, but this
would quickly become infeasible:
For example, a 256 by 256 pixel
image would already require a
transformer handling sequence
lengths of over 63,000 tokens;
a Full HD image of 1920x1080 would require
already a sequence length of over 2 million!
This is not scalable, and we
can completely forget scaling up
native deep learning processing to 4K images
– who is crazy enough to even want to do that?
Anyway, so now we’ve seen that ViT
first splits up the image into patches,
in order to keep the sequence
length within computational bounds.
But this is problematic for tasks that
require detailed processing of every pixel.
So, let’s look at how the Swin
Transformer wants to tackle this problem:
The Swin Transformer still relies on patches,
but instead of choosing one size and sticking
with it, the Swin Transformer first starts with
small patches for the first Transformer layer,
then merges them into bigger ones
in the deeper Transformer layers.
This reminds us of something, Ms. Coffee Bean…
Yeah, of U-Net and convolutions.
Now, let’s not get distracted here.
So the Swin Transformer takes in the image
And splits the image into 4x4 patches.
Each patch is still a colored image,
with three channels. So a patch has a
4x4x3 equals 48 feature dimensionality,
which is then linearly transformed
to a dimensionality C of your choice.
So the only difference to ViT so
far is that the patches are smaller.
But what about this size C, and what does it mean?
Well, C determines the capacity, or
the size of your Transformer model.
So you maybe know that there is a BERT-base
text model, which has a dimensionality
of 768 for the vector representations?
Well, in that case, C is 768.
There is also a BERT large with C=1024.
C is the capacity of the
model because it determines
the parameter size or the amount of hidden
units in the fully connected layers over here.
Just to get an impression about the
Swin Transformer, for Swin-Tiny,
C is 96 and 192 for Swin-Large.
But where were we? At the Swin Transformer that
has divided the image into
initial 4 by 4 pixel patches
and a linear transformation converting
each patch into a C-dimensional vector.
Transformer blocks process these patch vectors but
not with the usual quadratically scaling
attention, but with the Shifted Window based
Self-Attention introduced by the authors.
This is just a fancy name for
saying that the attention span is
limited over M patches (here two).
So now in self attention, one patch does
not communicate with all other patches,
but only with M neighbors.
I am so sure that I saw this
window limited self-attention
before in another paper under a different name.
Ms. Coffee Bean, do you remember where?
No. Oh, I’ll ask the audience then.
If you saw this kind of attention before,
or something very similar to it, then
please let us know in the comments where.
It was probably an NLP paper. Ok, in any case,
the limited attention window basically simulates
for let’s say, this first image patch token here,
that the rest of the sequence that is not in
its M neighborhood, basically disappeared.
This means that instead a quadratically scaling
attention computation with the sequence length,
we now have something linear for small M.
Great, so now it is time to move further
to the next layer in the hierarchy here:
The output of a sequence of N patch vectors
is of course again N vectors because the
transformer is sort-of an autoencoder.
Now the output is merged by
a so-called “merging layer”.
This concatenates the vectors of
groups of 2x2 neighboring patches
(in the image, not in the sequence as it
is quite simplistically visualized here),
so from 4 of these C-dimensional vectors,
we now have one 4xC dimensional vector
and this is passed through
a linear layer which is basically a linear
dimensionality reducer from 4C to 2C dimensions.
Ok, let’s simplify here a bit: If in the beginning
we had 4 patches, now we would have 1 patch,
but note that the hidden representation has been
doubled in order to increase the capacity
to capture information from a larger region.
And then again, the whole process repeats:
a limited attention-span transformer module is
processing the output and this goes on and on.
But each time the attention window is
shifted with respect to the previous layer.
So if in the first layer, the attention was
limited to neighborhoods of these regions,
in the next layer the regions are
shifted (like in strided convolution)
such that patches that landed into
separate windows in layer one and could
not communicate, can now communicate at layer two.
Then the resulting patch vectors are
again merged by the merging layer
and the whole hierarchical procedure is repeated
depending on the chosen number of layers
or until no merging is possible
anymore, and this was basically it.
Ms. Coffee Bean has two more comments.
First, regarding the positional embeddings for the
Swin Transformer, we should say that in principle,
all kinds of positional embeddings are applicable.
But the authors found that positional
embeddings which are directly added to
the vector representation of the tokens
are not working as well as the relative
position bias in self-attention, a method very
similar to what we presented in this video.
And secondly: how good is the Swin Transformer?
Well, it outperforms ViT and
DeiT on image classification,
object detection and semantic segmentation.
It’s small objects in object detection where
we would expect to see improvements with the
Swin Transformer and of course, in semantic
segmentation where every pixel must be labelled.
However, make up your own mind about the
comparisons with the state-of-the art,
because, you know, like
most of the papers nowadays,
the baselines are not necessarily
tuned to be the strongest.
Look at semantic segmentation in Table 3: The
Swin Transformer implementation is compared
to the DeiT transformer counterpart
but only in it’s smallest version.
A single measurement for one configuration of DeiT
is not enough to see how this all
behaves when scaling the model,
especially when in terms of number of parameters,
DeiT small is even smaller than Swin Tiny.
Not really a worthy opponent
for Swin-Large here, right?
Make up your own mind about this and let
us know in the comments what you think.
Which vision transformer variant is the one that
determined you to leave the ViT model and use
another variant (if any)? Ms. Coffee
Bean would be curious about that.
If you liked this content, do not forget
to leave a like to help with the YouTube
algorithm. Ms. Coffee Bean, I am curious to know
if THE YT Algorithm is transformer-based or not.
Ms. Coffee Bean?
Where are you going, I did not end the video yet.
Well, I guess it ended now.
Okay bye!.